[Musique]
hong kong
des prix qui s'envolent sur les marchés
du jamais vu depuis 20 ans et une
monnaie qui dégringole face au dollar
dans ce quartier populaire d'istanbul
faire ses courses relève de plus en plus
du casse tête pour les nombreux
retraités et mère au foyer comme fait
bratsch eric obligé de se rationner on
sait la tshopo oui je n'avais jamais
connu des prix aussi élevés avant je
remplissais complètement mon caddie
maintenant regarder s'il ya moitié vit
dans l'idée aujourd'hui je n'ai pas pu
acheter de concombres le prix a été
multiplié par six je peux pas me le
permettre
c'est tout ce qui me reste
alors la scène mode et ne vaut plus rien
et je ne sais pas combien de votre
au supermarché les étiquettes des
produits de première nécessité change
chaque jour et donnent le tournis aux
consommateurs en trois mois le prix de
l'huile a augmenté de 76%
86% pour la farine 47% pour le lait
66% pour les oeufs sur les réseaux
sociaux les turcs en rit jaune
on fait défiler le bidon d'huile au prix
de luxe sur tapis rouge comme une star
on lan ferme avec les oeufs dans un
coffre fort comme un trésor des
caricatures critique subtile de la
gestion du président turc recep erdogan
privilégie une mode et basses pour
favoriser la vente des produits turcs à
l'étranger et il limoge à la chaîne
ministres et gouverneurs de banques qui
le contredisent le risque perdre la
confiance de turc des classes et
l'inflation est tel qu'ils sont de plus
en plus à acheter du pain subventionné
par la mairie d'istanbul des scènes
jamais vu en 40 ans oubliée la turquie
vanté pour son modèle de croissance
ici le pain est deux fois moins cher que
dans les boulangeries je fais une heure
de route chaque jour pour venir petit à
petit on va s'arrêter de boire et de
manger
on a toujours dit que la situation de la
turquie était bonne mais ceux qui ont
profité de la croissance c'est surtout
les proches et les fidèles du parti au
pouvoir ils se sont enrichis pendant que
le peuple avait de plus en plus de
difficultés
un ras-le-bol qui commence à s'exprimer
dans la rue mobilisation syndicale de
5000 travailleurs à istanbul en décembre
contestation universitaire à ankara
violemment réprimées
quand dénis sachs ou est l'un des
étudiants arrêtés poursuivis pour avoir
dénoncé l'augmentation des loyers chez
lui d'anciennes caricature du président
erdogan qu'il estime responsables de la
crise
bon c'est tellement drôle là on voit que
les gens en colère commence à résister
nous les étudiants on a osé malgré la
répression j'espère que cette crise
économique va entraîner un changement
politique
les manifestations de colère reste
encore rare par peur de la répression
mais le mécontentement de la population
pourrait se traduire dans les urnes
selon les dernières enquêtes d'opinion
la cote de popularité du président r
douanes n'a jamais été aussi basse et il
est donné largement perdant aux
élections présidentielles prévues
l'année prochaine